hello everyone how's everybody doing
I hope you're doing fine at it that you
did not catch the virus okay today were
gonna have a dark day so I'm properly
dressed I think in black hey I was going
to talk today about waves
electromagnetic waves and instead the
this deal about the virus it takes
precedence okay so there is going to be
a virus day a viral day hopefully
anyways first I want to remind everyone
we have a conference in Lusaka Africa
Lusaka Zambia and maybe that's a good
place to go because as far as I know
Zambia has not recorded any cases now
someone might say well that's because
they're a backward country maybe they
have a million cases and they don't know
about it yeah it could happen but right
now it's a good bet that if you want to
escape the virus go to Lusaka okay so
that's a good place to go if the
authorities let you because right now
we're having a lot of problems at the
airports as we will see today okay there
is implementing draconian measures
governments and airports and Airlines
everybody's out of their minds right and
also my reminding people that we've
uploaded the book the rope hypothesis
you can locate it at rope hypothesis
calm and just go to books and there you
can download the book for free and I'll
put you up to date on the rope model of
light ok and gravity for those of you
who have a second language you can
contact us at toka cockeyed hotmail.com
and you know you may want to translate
it to your native language ok we would
send you a file that you can modify you
know
then repost it put you on the honor roll
okay anyways when we start with a virus
okay
this is the map as of Wednesday okay of
where the corona virus hit the world you
can see that China's on the number one
on the list they lost a lot of people
there it's the country that's got the
most cases then you have other countries
such as Japan Iran countries in Central
Europe and the United States which are
catching up let's say okay that was on
Wednesday okay what happened today today
March 15 well I don't know if it spread
a little more or if it's simply the fact
that we don't have enough information
okay so so we don't really know what's
going on or we know there are cases out
there we don't know how dangerous it is
because at least more than half of the
people who caught the virus surpassed it
in other words apparently more people
survived the virus than died of it it's
old people like me who died okay which
may not be so bad you know I mean for
those of you who heard Logan's Run you
know there was a movie on this case
where they had this ideal Society or
futuristic society where the young
people had to die at the age of 30
because at the age of 30 you were
considered to be an old man and so this
allowed the new generation to move up
into those positions into those new jobs
etc and they kept their population
overall always young and the problem
today are the old people me see if you
could get us out of the way all the old
workers then the young workers could
take their positions and we would have a
you would think a progressive society
but it's the old folks that are causing
this bottleneck for the new generation
okay and also because of that the new
generation doesn't have money they don't
have much of a future a lot of them and
so they don't produce kids they don't
get married they don't produce kids and
so the population becomes older and
older and older in general okay and so
we call that the overturning of the
population pyramid or the overturning of
the demographic pyramid okay
okay here's a rundown what happened
because of that that was the health part
you know the virus taken over the world
right one person here another there
the panic it caused far surpasses the
the death capabilities of the virus
itself
here you see Yahoo Finance this is what
they had on Friday yay and it shows that
you know you stock markets go crazy they
looked at the economic consequences
airlines have spent flights to China
streets are deserted theaters
restaurants that's all gone nobody goes
to travel anymore stock market falls
okay and especially the big five or some
of the big players okay they're all
going down and so you say you know here
you have this little bug and look at all
the disaster it's caused is it because
the bug is so lethal it's killing
millions no no so far we can say that a
drop of water in the ocean has occurred
this bug killed I don't know four
thousand five thousand people in the
world 100 some thousand people caught it
and and we are eight billion people on
the planet so eight billion people now
are held hostage because of a few cases
you know the question is whether the you
know the remedy is worse than the the
bug and the disease and that make
you stop and think are we overreacting
or is this overreaction the correct way
to contain the bug so it doesn't spread
further or should be allowed to kill
people and whoever survives survives and
we don't mess around with the economy at
least you know because maybe the economy
kills us before the bug does okay that's
the issue here's a shot of the airport
in in United States
that's essentially what all airports
look like not only in the United States
and here in Europe and other plays and
places as well okay so Europe scrambles
okay there there's a big problem there
because the US president says no one can
come into his country and people can
leave or when they come they're gonna be
in a lot of trouble because they're
gonna be put a you know they're gonna be
quarantine gonna be put in the airport
somewhere for a few days to make sure
the guys clean and then he he can be he
can be let go you know he can be
released to the pub to the general
population you'll be in prison for a few
days probably and that's gonna be or
it's being implemented in several
countries okay so you gotta be careful
about that because when you travel you
know you're you're gonna be held hostage
not so much in the receiving country
which may not care like if will you go
to Zambia they might not care there but
when you come back you might be in a lot
of trouble and troubled by the trouble I
mean that you know they're gonna ask you
questions they're gonna put you outside
they're gonna make life a little bit
miserable for you that's what I mean
right so what happened on Friday well I
decided to film the stock market ticker
okay here it is looks for a few seconds
okay and this is at four times the speed
it started about 950 and it went all the
way to a thousand okay and you're saying
why does the Dow go up so fast okay
who would be betting on the market when
when we have such a disaster you know
happening all around us nobody's even
leaving their houses in
Italy in Spain right now you know they
got the police checking the streets and
this is how the stock market ended up
you know you can see the roller coaster
in green up there went up and down that
day and it ended up at three point sixty
three above starting point so that
wasn't such a bad day for the market it
was a little bit of a recovery a little
bit of you know relief from what had
happened the first week or the earlier
week because stock market had gone down
not recovered and you're saying who
would be betting on the market at this
dire times in these dire times you know
why would anyone be betting on the
market and more I'll give you a little
more evidence here you want evidence
I'll give you a little bit of evidence
here you have Boeing you know Bowie
stock went up seven percent one of the
high rollers that day they they made a
little bit of money you know you say boy
I thought Boeing sold airplanes doesn't
point make airplanes for for the airline
industry your line industry is paralyzed
nobody's traveling hotels are shut down
and restaurants are shut down the whole
travel industry is suffering and these
guys are investing in airplanes now
something doesn't seem right you know
and yeah if you look at it it's people
betting against the future or in favor
of the future there they're big on the
future okay they're saying okay now the
stock goes down but eventually that's
that's a dip then it's gonna recover and
I'm gonna make a killing that's the
logic behind that because otherwise who
would be you know buying Boeing stock
you just be selling it right no they say
you gotta play the opposite side of the
market you let other people sell you buy
cheap and then sell big when you know
when the stock market recovers and so
all these people who are doing this the
the people who are putting the money in
stocks they're thinking things are going
to get better okay eventually because
you know we've seen it through history
there's always been dibs there's been
depressions deep recessions and
market recovers and if you were wise and
bought when it was low well now you made
a killing so it's it's it's okay the
logic is okay yeah that's that's what
I'm trying to say here right there's
nothing wrong with the logic the
question is whether history is any
indication of what's going on today okay
well the markets recover okay and here
let me show you uh projections these are
projections that I found the other day
this is what they project they projected
the world is gonna still grow despite
the bug 2.4 percent this is the entire
planet in 2020 it's a little down from
what their our original predictions were
I don't remember but the original
prediction was but they're saying that
still can grow 2.4 percent you see the
United States it was supposed to grow at
2.3 was only going to grow at 1.9 the EU
European Union it's gonna grow it was
supposed to grow 1.2 it's only going to
grow at 0.8 India a little more than
than what it was originally planned for
in China little less so people are
projecting that the world is still going
to go up as far as the values what we're
going to produce the economic growth of
the planet you have a disease that's
essentially put everybody inside their
houses and say you're in prison inside
your houses right and the projections
are that we're still going to grow there
seems to be a little bit of a
contradiction where some people are very
hopeful I don't know yeah everybody's
got their own version of what may happen
in the future some people are not
worried at all some people are ultra
worried they go out and buy toilet paper
I guess put under walls all over the
place ok yeah yeah I like this one you
know he's he's got his RV he says for
the end of the world 18 tons so if you
want an armored truck to run around the
country you know free of bugs and so on
well there it is you can buy that
so the RV for the end of the world you
get your camper you travel around your
nobodies you know you're a free person
you know you know and one of the things
that brings up is the fact that many
people in the last maybe 50 60 years
after World War two I would say for sure
started talking more and more about the
end of the world
you've got end of the world songs which
I just went in there and got a few songs
that just popped in my mind in the
search and you'll see all these songs
they have to do with end of the world
scenarios you know and why is that it do
we have like a sixth sense where we
think something is happening we feel it
in our bones that something is not quite
right is that what it is or is it just a
fad that people say well you know it's a
nice subject to talk about the end of
the world you know you know you've had
all these movies like Waterworld and so
on and the question is is this that
we're sensing that something is not
right or is it just a fad it's a nice
subject to talk about what's the issue
here I mean you had you had people talk
about like the end of the world when the
first thousand years of the Christian
era came you know a protein they said oh
the thousand years the millennium we're
gonna have Jesus Christ come back to
earth and then we had the year the twos
the year 2000 the second movie a lot of
people committed suicide and so on you
know okay you know it it's whatever you
believe but the question is you know is
this something new the fact that we have
so much talk lately or movies or art
here here I collected just good or the
Wikipedian you'll find this you know
this is what you'll find these are
end-of-the-world entertainment we can
call it okay you've got everything you
got art you got books you got films
television songs the whole thing the
whole works
you know you
and all kinds of end-of-the-world
scenarios and people talking about it
people writing songs about it is this
our sixth sense
do we feel that something is not right
is that what we're I mean what would we
talk about it and I want to give you a
comparison with the 19th century 19th
century was an era of growth
manufacturing was exploding new
inventions were coming in too you know
on the line end of the 19th century
beginning of the 20th century you had
the telephone it put a lot of people to
work you had the car industry you had
the airplane you had all these
inventions and people went out there and
they got jobs you know there was no
problem really with with work in general
in general there was a lot of demand for
workers and so people were hopeful and I
don't think too many people talked about
the end of the world or or wrote songs
about it or anything like that you look
at the lyrics of the 19th century
pushing the United States and I don't
think you'll find a single one talking
about the end of the world here you just
I just showed a little you know piece of
it with what you find out there you'll
find a lot more songs talking about the
end of the world scenarios and so on and
talking about that prospect okay so I
don't know there's something going on
here and so we have two possibilities
either this virus is triggering the end
of the world or it's not I mean how's
that for black and white okay you either
believe that this virus is gonna take us
to the end of the world it's the
beginning of the end or you think you
this is just a normal dip and we're
gonna recover markets are gonna recover
jobs are going to recover we're gonna
all go back to normal and when when they
find an antidote or whatever you know on
a vaccine for the virus and for 20 years
now I've been talking about the
extinction of man and I already said
many times now that what's going to
cause the extinction of man is the the
collapse of the global economy and right
now you have a nice an interesting
situation where this bug could cause the
extinction of man not because of the bug
not because we're all going to get
infected it's not a disease that's gonna
kill us
but the bigger impact is on the market
on the on economics on the man's
artificial economy because people panic
they lose their jobs companies close
down or you know they're they go
bankrupt because of panic or because of
government intervention you know and
what this does is creates this ambient
of hysteria okay people are in panic
mode and I guess it's not the bug it's
gonna be the panic mode that's gonna
cause it we should be worried more about
the the panic and the hysteria then we
should be worried about the bug itself
and so yeah I I said you know the it's
cause what's gonna cause the collapse of
man of our species what's gonna cause
the extinction of our species is the
collapse of the economy and that could
very well happen orchids triggered by
this bug now it could trigger it or it
may be something else maybe this is just
a dry run of what's gonna happen
sometime later maybe in one year maybe
two years making it five or and ten this
is a good dry run a new reader a good
rehearsal for what may be coming our way
what happens when when there's a panic
people go for food now that's
interesting I always said it's food
right so people are worried about food
right now okay they go out there and
they buy food because he got a stuck up
because they don't know what's coming
and the first thing people think about
is food now what would you think that's
the case yeah food is important you know
food is very important for everybody
thinks of food and I said you know the
global collapses is is an issue of food
is strictly an issue of food
why because if the global economy
collapses no one produces or delivers
food to the cities yeah that means that
suddenly were separated from that which
is vital to us that sustains us you know
the old days of hunter-gathering people
had their own Spears our ancestors you
know they had Spears it was good that
you would kill an animal and they had
direct contact with their food in a
sense right it was dependent it was
depending on how much skill they had or
whatever how much how many animals they
had at their disposal to kill how easy
they weren't so on today we are being
spoon-fed you know someone else produces
our food and we don't have a direct
contact with food okay so how do we get
food what we pay for it
and we pay for it with money and what
happens if money collapses what if money
is no more which is my argument for man
okay what happens when money no one
believes in money anymore and you say
well that's impossible bill it'll never
happen well the first thing I want to
remind you is at some point in time we
did not have any money now some people
believe we've always had money some kind
of money no no we didn't there was no
such thing as trade or commerce in the
upper Palaeolithic and people who think
that are simply ignorant people okay
what can I say
Neanderthals did not use money even
though you have people like John Hawkes
who says oh they traded seashells for I
don't know for prostitution I don't know
these people are crazy and they're in
there anthropologists and
paleontologists they know nothing about
the basics no no I had to gather
official especially a basal
hunter-gatherer he does not use money he
takes care of his own food he hunts by
himself or with a group of people from
his own clan but he doesn't go out there
and do the other clan and across the
river especially a different species and
say hey you guys you want to trade here
we have some some seashells that we can
give you for
for I don't know bearskin I mean these
people are crazy totally crazy and so no
there was no trade trade began after
commercial after subsistence agriculture
began and then shortly I don't know if
shortly but if at least maybe 2000 years
later that's when they invented trade
they invented bartering you would give
something exchange for something else if
you trusted the other guy maybe he goes
from your own village and you trusted
him more or less but you're not going to
go out there in the wild and chain and
exchange with you know a hyena
exchanging deer bones with a lion it
just doesn't happen but that's what
these people have in their minds because
all they think about is trade trade
trade and think that everything is trade
no no in the jungle you don't trade
because it wouldn't you if you do your
trade in your life that's what your
trade the other guy guess what you have
in you that gets both of you ok so yeah
when I look at extinction I start with
the Cretaceous and I show that what died
died because of food and here you have
the Cretaceous terrestrial revolution it
shows you why the dinosaurs died was it
because of a Nast ride like the idiots
of paleontology say today which is the
official version no absolutely not you
can see here this graph which was
collected at data collected from after
four years okay and they assembled this
graph and what it shows is that the
flowering plants displaced the
gymnosperms Janey the angiosperms
replaced the gymnosperms that's what
happened over a long period of time
these are millions of years right and
you can see the number of species
expanded in and also the number of the
quantity for each species yeah and what
they did they crowded out the
gymnosperms and of course if you're
gonna crowd out the gymnosperms and
that's what the dinosaurs ate well then
for sure you know you're gonna have
trouble surviving and so what happened
these animals were big they were eating
these these things that the grasses
we're taking over the land in squeezing
them out and that's going to cause at
some point the extinction of the animals
that dependent on the conifers for such
a long time which developed a symbiotic
relationship with the conifers that
explains much better why the dinosaurs
died and if you go throughout the
history of life on earth you'll find the
same pattern I mean don't take my word
for it just do a little research and
you'll find out what died were the old
species in the case of the dinosaurs
with died were the old species ok the
ones on the left they were the dinosaurs
right they died and the so did the
plants that they ate they were pushed
aside by the newcomers who were the
newcomers well the mammals in the case
of the animals and the mammals in the
case of the animals and in the case of
the plants were the flowering plants
they displaced the conifers so it's very
simple we don't need an asteroid to do
this in fact an asteroid cannot explain
chronological selectivity which is what
you're staring at the old species died
the new species survived no asteroid can
do that ok unless it's a very smart
asteroid you know you'll find the same
thing for the Permian Permian would died
you know again where the ferns Pressley
the seed ferns and the animals that
depended on the seed firms and what
continued were the arcus ours
those were the animals that took over
the land and then you have the long
necks of the Jurassic they took over the
language of the Triassic animals lost
their their food sources which again
were like they crow diems and and plants
of that nature which were again all a
different type of seed ferns so it's
when the plants die because their
population pyramid overturns after
millions of years they lose genetic
diversity and little by little they
whittle away while new plants take over
the land and then you know the animals
who forged the relationship over
millions of years with these old plants
with these ancient plants they go
together with the plants that they ate
that's all there is that's
mass extinction so what does that have
to do a man what does it have to do with
a bug well in the case of man we produce
our own food there's there's no
difference really it's just that we
produce our own food
we manufacture distribute our own food
we have this system that we created but
we depend on food as well we don't eat
like for two months I think we're gonna
die a billion of us some people say how
can you kill a billion you can kill
eight billion people by starving them to
death you know if God comes to earth
instead of raining you know for
showering us with rains for 40 days and
40 nights he does something different he
waves his magic wand and now the earth
you know looks like the surface of the
Moon okay now you can't plant anything
do you think you would die in that case
there you know nothing to plant nothing
to harvest nothing to sell it's far I
mean we could still have computers we
could still have buildings we can have
highways we can have cars and airplanes
if you don't have food you die you don't
need all this other stuff those are not
those are nice to haves but what you
absolutely need to have is food and
water okay liquids right so so this is
the issue the issue is that if the
economy falls apart and what I mean by
that is money is no more right money is
no more than what connects our entire
economy disappears the little chain that
connects us that disappears and so now
you can't go to the store and pay with
money because the store won't accept
money the store can't buy new product
because the manufacturer doesn't accept
money the producer doesn't sell to the
manufacturer because he doesn't accept
money and the worker doesn't accept
money but you know for his labor because
he has no use for money he can't go to
store and buy stuff with money so if
money disappears we got a serious
problem
you know we can kill all of humanity
simply by having God come over with his
magic wand
and making money disappear and so yeah
people say well that's impossible
self-interest and they'll come up with a
whole bunch of theories or arguments for
why money won't disappear ok this this
is this is what people have in their
minds they've been so conditioned to
money you know that that they don't
think it's possible for money to
disappear so let me just show a little
thing here you can see it what the
politicians are doing today they're
chopping up hope what is uh money it's
that's trust it's faith that's how it is
and if the politicians going to chop up
hope what you're chopping up is In God
We Trust if we don't trust that income
atheists and money is that possible well
you know again if it's just hope if
that's all that money is it's just me
trusting that I can do something with
the money you give me well that's kind
of wishy-washy isn't it I mean here's
someone comes tomorrow and says bill
I'll give you money okay
here's money here's money from Argentina
okay
you see these bills put it over here
that's Argentine money okay 500 pesos
okay and so I go to your shop and I pay
you with 500 argentine pesos how could
you accept them you might say well I
don't think I'll accept those Vietnamese
money instead
I mean it's legal tender it's backed by
the government of Argentina what more do
you want
so money is that money is not money
there is money and there's money some
things you don't accept I go with a bit
of gold and I say hey I want to buy your
bike but I don't have any cash on me
I'll I'll give you I'll give you some
gold coins you say okay I'll take those
well you will you'll take
this mental sure okay - no no problem
okay then I'm gonna give you a limestone
instead you know
will you accept I've got two rocks I can
get some more if you if you want you
know rocks would you accept it I mean
money is money right so the guy says no
no I want the shiny one I don't want
that limestone or whatever somebody is
not money is not money okay so there is
money there's things you will accept
some stuff you won't accept okay and the
question is what happens when the global
economy falls apart
will you accept money from your own
country you know will will an American
accept dollars will at European accept
euros and again the question is whether
you can use it again because if you
don't have faith you don't have trust
you lost your faith in money and you
don't accept it because you think you
may have problems getting rid of that
money you know buying stuff with it
because money is being devalued daily
and companies are laying off people and
now the salaries are not worthy in other
words the they don't have real value
will you accept money the guy gives you
money and it turns out with money you
can't even make it to the end of the
month you got to pay your rent you gotta
pay maybe some bills you gotta buy food
you're gonna if you have kids you gotta
maintain your kids maybe something with
college and it turns out that the money
they give you as a salaried worker
proletarian right is not good enough to
get you to the end of the month what
happens you get to that stage would you
continue an assist
oh yeah I'll continue working for for 90
percent of what I need to get to the end
of the month it is that possible can you
work for less than what you need to
survive I mean as long as this money is
worth more and you can still make it to
the end of the month you might still
drag on and say
okay I think I can make it but if you're
at 90 percent of your expenses would you
go to work and so this is the issue can
money fall below a certain value that
nobody gives a damn about money anymore
or more and more people stop paying
attention to money because money is no
longer cutting it for them and some
people say well you know money cannot
disappear and here we have a big problem
because people don't understand English
so let me teach you a little bit of
English okay let's teach you a little
bit of English so that you know what
what we have here and it's the
difference between can and will people
don't seem to understand the difference
okay can has to do with possible will
has to do with probable can I destroy
money yeah I can't I get a match put a
dollar bill and I burn in it I can make
money disappear I can burn it I can kill
it
I can also press the button on the
computer wipe out a bank account
suddenly I got rid of a whole bunch of
money where I go to Bill Gates of town
you know hack it and say bill you know
all those my brother Bill gave you Bill
Gates all those billions of dollars you
had in stocks click one button no more
so how does Bill how much is Bill Gates
worth in the next morning when he finds
out his entire stock has been wiped
clean okay so we can destroy money can
possible okay
just like we something there was a time
when we never had money a long time ago
thousands of years ago in the same way
we can end up with not needing or not
having money or because money
disappeared money collapses we lose our
faith in money or whatever so can yes we
can we're talking about tan here about
whether it's possible and people say no
no but see when people do for their own
self-interest
blah-blah-blah-blah-blah no no that's
the second one that's will that's
probable whether they will or not it's
like you know I got a dollar bill can I
burn it yeah I can Bernie will I burn it
that's a separate issue for
self-interest I may not burn it because
I said well I can buy something with it
I can get something but this dollar
that's different than saying I cannot
burn it okay so so people are confusing
the self-interest and they start
introducing issues of will of
probability versus issue of can and
possibility the first thing we have to
accept is that it's possible to kill
money it's possible physically possible
yeah you can wipe out money through the
internet you can you can do a lot of
things of money governments can tomorrow
wipe out money sometimes you would think
they're they're doing exactly that I
mean if the Fed suddenly increases the
money supply doubles it or whatever you
know you can do that if they can will
they do that that's a separate issue but
they can and if they double the money
supply maybe money's not worth any much
anymore or they can do something you
worse they can give everybody a million
dollars how's that for destroying money
they give everybody in the country a
million dollars everybody's a
millionaire now now would that be great
I don't know maybe it's not because he
if everybody's got a million dollars
maybe at least half of them if not more
will not go to work anymore they say
well I don't need to work out I'm gonna
go on vacation and so you're gonna pay
for services that you're not going to
give because that person also went on
vacation
everybody goes on vacation and suddenly
nobody goes to work and everybody's a
millionaire the great world you know
we're all millionaires and here we all
have a million dollars and we can't do
anything one of it so can we destroy
money yeah there are many ways to
destroy money and make sure that money
is no more and I'm talking about can
possibility people don't always
understand that they immediately run
into with their minds into probability
and they think they're there they're
they have an antidote to can to
possibility so let's get that straight
we can destroy money if we put all our
heads together you know
we're gonna say tomorrow money is no
more we can do that if we want will we
do that that's a separate issue and
people raise issues of probability of
self-interest of of that nature right
but here that's not the argument that's
not the argument I'm raising I'm not
saying that it's an issue of whether we
will do it purposely like you know
deliberately where we gonna go in there
and say we're gonna destroy money the
Fed is gonna double the money or give
everybody a million dollars though
that's not what I'm saying I'm saying
there certain situations where money
simply or contacts right where money has
no value your ship sinks okay and so the
entrepreneur you know the money
conscious person he goes instead of
going to the kitchen grabbing what he
might need on the island no he grabs the
treasure chest and swims you know this
treasure chest
all the way to shore well he's a
millionaire on the island but he's got
nothing to eat what is his money worth
there so context I think is to some
degree quite important you know you got
to look at context other situations
where the circumstances determine that
money is no more whether you like it or
not it's not a question of whether you
want money to disappear it's an issue of
its imposed upon you because you have no
choice and just imagine if this virus
continues the the coronavirus right and
so the government now imposes more
draconian measures and private companies
also and I look at Spain look at Italy
if you've heard a little bit about that
you know they're now the streets are
policed it won't allow you outside your
street unless you have a reason to be on
the streets like you know you're gonna
buy groceries okay you might be allowed
to go through if you don't bribe the
policemen you have to bribe maybe to get
through maybe you're going to work
because you got to go to work and not
everybody can work
home maybe you're going to the hospital
so there are a few situations under
which you can leave your city but
everybody is under lockdown you know a
lot of towns and yes the whole country
in Spain is under lockdown in Italy
probably - so the question is this is
imposed upon you and if it's imposed
like that by the force of arms in a
democratic country right we might have a
little bit of a problem because that
might affect the flow of goods the free
flow even of ideas if you come to think
of it you know you got a look at that
possibility and yeah it could come to a
point where a lot of people lose their
jobs because companies shut down because
nobody's buying or buying very little so
companies shut down they lay off people
and because they lay off people there's
less income out there less disposable
income to act as a good democratic
freedom-loving consumer okay and so you
don't buy another company shuts down
kicks off workers and then the cycle
continues and here's the picture it's
called a chain reaction
yeah this is the corona chain reaction
you know Kronus the strikes people
that's the starting point
so people react now first government
says oh Jesus we got to do something
about this so they put a lot of news and
the news is sensationalist headlines oh
two people died in our country oh my god
that shut down the country you know it's
those panic spreads and then what
happens corporations lose that revenue
especially for example tourism right and
in other words what we're talking about
is restaurants what else
shops hotels you know Airlines so on and
so they lose revenue now they kick off
work they kick workers out or they say
hey why don't you take
leave of absence without pay so now this
guy has less money and so he's got less
money to spend which means now the
consumers stop buying and then the cycle
stops starts again it goes back to the
corporation losing more revenue more
workers lose their jobs and fewer
consumers buy things so it's a chain
reaction that is exponential and it's
self self feeding it's a self feeding
mechanism and so yeah you can have the
situation where in a very short time
because of this exponential process you
just have one thing right after another
and the whole thing just collapses and
it doesn't even give you time to breathe
that doesn't give you time to take that
deep breath to think about what's
happening so could it happen well I
think it could now is it gonna happen
well that's a separate issue we got to
wait and see what happens but right now
it doesn't look very good and again if
this is not what's gonna cause the
collapse of man it does give us a drug a
dry run of what may happen in the future
when we have a similar situation not
triggered necessarily by a bug could be
triggered by simply the loss of jobs too
many people unemployed and people who
workers go out into the streets they
protest because they don't have a job
they don't have an income the government
might give some welfare out or some
unemployment benefits and maybe even
some health insurance and that's not
enough and the person barely makes it to
the end of the month how do they do that
well they have to take away from the
person who works and that person now
gets less money because you know he's
got to support all these people who
don't work and at some point there is a
collapse of the economy because you
can't keep having more and more
unemployed people or making just barely
enough to live a lot of people clinging
to the system through welfare through
unemployment through retirement retirees
are unemployed people gay housewives etc
students and so you have this mass of
workers who are making less and less and
less and more and more people hanging
to them at some point the system
collapses and at that point what I mean
by that I mean money is no more and so
you don't need a bug to produce that the
bug if anything just awakened a few
people out there that it could happen
you know I have friends out there they
have now thinking about when I said all
these fears they say well maybe you were
not completely wrong you know there's
still got there still have they still
have faith in the system but yeah it
just gives you an idea that if we let
this go on it might produce you know the
final straw that breaks the camel's back
okay I'm gonna continue on Wednesday
probably with wave electromagnetic wave
while I analyze what I was supposed to
analyze today and so I'm gonna leave
that till Wednesday so we'll see you
then
and hopefully you don't catch the corona
virus and hopefully they don't stop in
your town they don't stop you from
buying groceries we'll see you then bye
bye